I want to start with I love the first
season I've seen all of season two loved
season two I need you to keep making
more of these so I'm very happy Apple
has already greenlit three and four so
yeah we love it too we like doing it
yeah yeah because it's fantastic the
writing is delicious
um before I get into the show I like
throwing a curveball at the beginning
um for both of you if someone has
actually never seen anything that you've
done before what is the first thing
you'd like them watching and why
yeah I'm awfully proud of
JFK I have a pivotal role
but not a huge role in the in the film
but
um
I thought what Oliver did uh with it was
just
really quite something and it was it's
I think the first movie that I saw I was
invited to a small screening of it
and it was the first movie that I was in
where I thought
life
can't believe I can't believe I'm in
this film you know that I'm involved and
that I'm part of it I thought it was I
think it's one of it's It's to me it's
one of it's Oliver's one of his
masterpieces actually okay so that I
think that would be that would be a good
one for me yeah and I yeah I did um I
think it was my third or fourth film
independent small budget film that
Michael winterbottom directed called
butterfly kiss yep which um I loved
loved doing that
and um
made some good long friend you know
lifelong friends after that film but
that was really exciting for me and I
loved the
I loved the way it developed
and uh
yeah
that'll be a good place to start one of
the things Gary I want to ask you an
individual question uh when I was
watching season two I noticed that um
let me say it like this when you read
the scripts for season two and you saw
how much you would be eating in every
scene did you say yes or did you say I
need a rewrite
no no no I just yeah it's um
you know there's certain things that
that come that come with the job there's
there's certain things that come with
Jackson
um he smokes
now I that I have these herbal uh
pretend
cigarettes but nevertheless
um he smokes he drinks
he eats and these are all part of the of
the character and I
I was saying I was saying to saskia I I
hate I don't like that thing when actors
pretend to eat
when they're um when they're when they
have a scene with a meal
and you can see them cutting and then
like moving their food around the plate
I can't I can't it's like when people
pour tea
and and they and they pour it like that
and you know that they've only put that
you know little things like that really
irk me you know what I mean pour the tea
eat the food
um and so yeah
I mean Jackson lamb would just
devour those noodles the only thing is
of course you you don't do it once you I
you do it 20 times I think I actually
went I had about 20 bowls of noodles
that day that's what I was meaning is
that I have a lot of friends that are
actors and they're like yeah when you're
shooting a food scene that could be ours
and you're eating and eating and eating
and eating
yeah yeah I mean I've that wasn't that
wasn't that wasn't so bad but I had been
in scenes where
um it's at the end of a meal and there's
Leftovers on the plate
and you keep coming back to it have you
ever had that where it's like really
rancid yeah it's yeah where it sits
under the lights
and um you know
if you're staring at a half-eaten Lamb
Chop
[Laughter]
for three days Under The Lights it's
it's it's it's not good yeah yeah in
season two uh you both get to do stuff
out of the office you I love the
production design of actual you know of
of the sets that have been built but
there has to be something that's great
about shooting on location in London and
just adds to the show so it just adds so
much to the show well I live in London
so this job is just a gift for me
you know um and uh I went to drama
school very near where we filmed the
outside of sloughhouse
and it's just such familiar territory
it's very nice to be
pretending to be this secretary woman
who goes to work at all gate you know
near the Barbican and it's great and I
think they've chosen some wonderful
unusual locations in London they're not
the the cliche images that we see of
London I think that's great
great choices and we shoot where he
played where he
where he
um conceived you can see the the that
building
uh that is slow house is the building
that Mick Herron used to walk past or
travel past on the bus every day to work
so he set it in that building in that
location and that is where we
that is where we film so um and in
season three
um where I have a I have a meet with um
with Ben Chapman in a laundrette is uh I
don't think we could get it with the
with the first season we couldn't we
couldn't lock in the location
but in the third season I mean uh Ben in
the launderette which is at the
launderette that he that is in the book
you know so we're very fortunate that we
that we all these all these different
landmarks
um yeah we the the the Russian
house you know where she goes and plays
chess
that was in the most extraordinary
location I had never I didn't know it
existed it was a a house right on the
Riverside in the East End of London and
it was like an oasis in this huge
Housing state and it was a very old
um
uh River Masters house and it was I
think it was a commune for a while it
was incredible old Georgian building
um and they built the set the set design
and the artistic design on this program
is exceptional I think
um
and they really they they really bring
out so many details and you know they
don't hold back on dust and grime and
it's just wonderful yeah pardon me for
not knowing but I guess you have film
season three are you filming three and
four right now we're still making it at
the moment
you know they're they're finishing off
uh season three
uh as we speak and then um I I think
Jack flies back soon to finish he's got
like a whole section of
plant stunt stuff yeah Jack flies in
um lands at 7 30 in the morning and go
straight to the set so uh
yeah they're still shooting and then
we're back in hopefully we're told
sometime in February to start season
four if I'm not mistaken you shot one
and two together or did you take a break
this is small bright we should we we
can't yeah we shot them oh kind of back
to back yeah yeah yeah yeah I was
wondering if you were going to do that
for three and four
um but apparently not
well they need time to prep so the heads
of Department everybody needs time to
put I mean I think their time has been
uh squashed a bit
um because
he has an exciting beginning for season
three isn't that Gary but no spoilers no
there is no a very good one and we we're
fortunate also that we're one of the few
showers if not the only show where we
have one director yeah for the six
episodes so
it in a sense
we get we get a director who is
I mean for all intents and purposes
making a six-hour movie
rather than a lot of shows where you
have a director who comes in for two and
then they switch out and then they shoot
you know they sort of
um we get I love the I I like the the
the familiarity of it and the and the
continuing the continuity of it yeah and
they don't need to stop I'm just going
to say I'm so happy you're making this
show and I wish you nothing but the best
good luck with the rest of your speed
dating thank you very much thank you